Just a quick recap on two shorts taken
on American crude oil, April 27th London
session.
So when session first opens, it stays
rotational within the value area.
Comes back into the extreme.
Retests the extreme here. Accepts back
into the value area. So once it does
this, we're going to assume it's going
to go to the next extreme and stay
rotational.
Which is exactly what happens. Hits the
inner deviation two on value area high.
We get the retest.
Enter off the retest.
Final TP is value area low of DVA.
Uh when I when I get these initial
um setups on the on the extreme, on the
standard deviation two, I don't go full
risk. I like to compound on these. Which
is exactly what we did. So I took third
of my risk here.
And then
we accept back into the value area. We
get a retest. Slightly comes back out of
the value area.
Once it comes back into the value area,
this is where we enter.
We almost got wicked out. It survived.
So this is where we put the rest of our
risk here.
And then
same thing, final TP was value area low
of the DVA.
And it worked out perfectly. Full TP on
both.
Um so again, with each each of my scalps
at the moment, I do a third of my risk.
So this total was 0.66% of my total
risk.
Um that's how I'm going to be playing it
out for now. And if anything changes in
the future, I'll let everybody know.